what kind of crappy suit is this by Jove
I think we've got it now we're on the
way I'll face camera no matter what it
takes we always cover the ass
heartbreaker will you help what's his
name
snapper
yeah challenging let's try that again
get back here you're fun too let's just
do it balanced ready what is not normal
that you challenging
where every direction is this point kind
of the office yeah yeah when you feel it
all the other direction act like you're
gonna like you're trying to counter it
okay go the other there you just like
that how many gags are you doing we're
going to do the incline one yeah after
this one but this one right now you're
more upright we're just gonna do a small
blender section hey I don't like my
little tummy there I'm not doing all
this crud that's all I'm saying
say hold the mass we could hold off on
this way back I need to see it
here's only then on my hammer right now
aren't you
he's up on the hammer twisted parlor
games going down here join me let's get
down what a start we can brace all the
bugs before
coulda saved a lot of trouble just
didn't know that'd be great
[Music]
it's not normal however it's challenging
the world's biggest terrorist to a
breakfast marry you gotta know what
hates Matt good to eat about ten minutes
before this right
[Music]
good scratch
either
[Music]